protests that have rocked portland for
102
straight days are spreading to other
parts of oregon more than 100 supporters
of president trump appeared last night
in salem that's about 45 miles from
portland they faced off against a small
number of black lives matter supporters
and the confrontation we have to say got
a little heated
luciano is outside the state capitol in
salem where the two sides scuffled last
night
lilia always good to see you i see that
it got a little dicey what are you
hearing from those rally goers now the
supporters of the president that i heard
from said they showed up here at the
capitol
to protect the building from people they
call antifa there was a standoff
and then violence
video from monday afternoon shows
several trump supporters chasing down a
black lives matter protester in salem
shooting him with paintballs and
tackling him that protester eddie
coleman spoke to the new york times
and when i stood my ground finally
one of them pushed me to the ground and
hit my face repeatedly we spoke to
people who claim the apparent attacks
were instigated by members of antifa
which is not a formal organization but
an anti-fascist
ideology i feel that it's absolutely
critical that we
stand our ground and say that we won't
be ran off by
violent insurrectionists it all came
after a peaceful pro-trump rally in
nearby oregon city
some attendees displayed blue lives
matter flags others with the phrase
don't tread on me a revolutionary war
message
now associated with far-right rhetoric
we're done remaining silent in the
united states of america
from there a smaller group headed to the
state capitol building
[Music]
those supporters appeared to include
members of the proud boys
a far right-wing group known for
promoting violence
several people openly carried
semi-automatic weapons
we can't have people going around
burning our cities down with no
consequences or anything
what's the goal of showing up with your
gun
or second amendment right
you want to protect everybody else out
here
everything can't happen it's just a
moment of wind
the people we spoke to said they were
not members of the proud boys and they
were within their legal right to carry
those weapons
in case you're wondering police did
intervene to stop the attacks
and they also arrested a couple of
people
lily thank you very much